[Music]
this is the story of hubris
this is a story of hype green still over
the last eight years
has significantly disrupted the way
working capital has delivered
it's one of those stories that's got
everything ambition
greed power money the dark corners of
the financial world and what goes
on in it this is the story of lex
reinstill
and his company greenstall capital a
financier
who flew too close to the sun it's a
story that involves
investment banks politicians it's also
the story of sanjeev gupta
steel works private jets trophy mansions
scandal intrigue is the biggest lobbying
scandal in british politics for a
generation
and it's a story that ends in tragedy
please understand that i bear complete
responsibility for the collapse of
greensville capital
lex greenstiller was obviously at the
center of all of this
he's sort of like this financial wizard
of ours lex greenstall was the ultimate
salesman
he had this rags to riches story of
being brought up the son
of watermelon farmers in australia
sometimes companies won't pay them fast
enough this would cause financial ruin
for his family
he ended up coming to the uk in his 20s
he started working as an investment
banker he then
left to create his own firm queensland
capital in 2011.
mr greenstall are you a fraudster
no mr connor i am not green soul capital
said it was making finance fairer and
helping small businesses get paid
faster actually did that by using quite
an
unsexy technique which is known as
supply chain finance
a supplier will sell something to a
company that company might not pay
for quite a long time the supplier
obviously wants to get paid as quickly
as possible instead of getting paid by
the company
they get paid by a bank or a company
like green silk
and then the bank will then reclaim that
money later from the company and take a
cut
of the money a big part of his pitch was
look small businesses
like my parents would have benefited
from having access to
the kind of financing that my company is
now providing
it became a big story because of the way
it was being used
problems come when you start doing it
for less credit worthy companies
the key accounting trick here is that
this transaction is not classed as debt
it lets companies hide how much debt
they really have
he talked about ai machine learning all
these buzzwords
how it's all going to make this
magically safe some people have
questioned whether it was the technology
that was the new thing
or whether it was the kind of smooth
brash salesman skills of lex greenseal
which enabled him to open so many doors
and to sell as his financing to so many
companies
disrupting entire kind of economies
takes time and therefore a long-term
view is critical
his whole story was central to the
company's rise
he'd talk about the red soil of
bundaberg that's the place he's from
and he'd say that he'd rather be on a
tractor than in a suit
it got him into the corridors of power
in uk government he had access to people
like david cameron
the former prime minister who would go
on to become an employee of greensol
capital
in 2018 general atlantic gave grinsell
250 million dollars a quarter of a
billion dollars
in investment a big new york based
very highly regarded private equity firm
they've got about 50 billion
dollars under management these are the
guys that backed facebook
alibaba and what's critical about that
is that it paves the way the following
year
for softbank to come along they invested
one and a half billion dollars softbank
wanted to follow in the footsteps of
general atlantic by
backing our continued growth on a global
basis
the whole thing reaches a whole other
scale at that point he's now this
titan of a tech company rather than just
a boring banker
a big part of the story was that they
were using artificial intelligence and
technology
to turn something that had been a boring
backwater of finance
into something that was much sexier and
more exciting and
something that could be branded fintech
general atlantic are supposed to be the
smartest guys in the room when it comes
to tech
the fact that they invested in
greensville it seemed to say to people
well these guys are legit really there
was very little technology
involved in what greenstone was doing
they were relying on third-party
companies to provide a lot of the
technology
it was really when he gets this venture
capital money
to feed his grand ambition that's when
the story really takes off
[Music]
in 2016 greenfield actually had a
horrible year
massive losses in 2017 it has this big
resurrection it suddenly books 100
million
in revenue over that it's incredible so
investors were looking at this and
they're like
wow this guy's actually cracked the
secret to this stuff
[Music]
the actual secret behind that was a man
called sanjeev gupta
without sanjiv gupta the story wouldn't
be the story
that we're now telling sanjeev gupta is
a british businessman who was born in
india
as a young man he went to turkey selling
bicycles for his father
he then went to cambridge university in
the uk he was kicked out of university
halls
for starting his own commodities
training business that would be the
start of liberty house
eight years ago he started buying up
steel and aluminium assets around the
world
from very large steel companies like
arsenal mittel
these are mostly unloved assets so
nobody really wanted them they were sort
of seen at the end of their life
he brought these up in very rapid
succession and built quite a big company
gfg alliance
he said that he had this way of
maintaining all the jobs but at the same
time
of making the steel works far more
environmentally sustainable
this really kicked off a run of
acquisitions around the world
scotland australia the united states
europe and
india he was buying everything steel
works aluminium smelters
car parts factories you name it people
saw him as a sort of savior of steel
saving lots of jobs governments liked
him the steel workers liked him
and others were always sort of wary you
know where's all the money coming from
why is he going to be able to do
something different that the large steel
companies haven't been able to do
within the metals industry it raised a
lot of questions people were saying who
is this guy
greenfield was the lender which enabled
a lot of this rapid rapid growth through
acquisition because
they were providing the finance forward
as we dug more into gupta's gfg alliance
we realized it had been built on
financial engineering
it was turning rusting steel works into
gold-plated finance
while he was trying to turn around a
number of these businesses he was still
going on the acquisition trail
and snapping up plants and factories
around the world within a few years
sanjeev gupta had built this industrial
empire
with 20 billion dollars in revenues and
35 000 employees
but because it was privately owned
nobody really knew how it was performing
he used these sort of supply chain
finance techniques from green soil
but he used them in very aggressive ways
so this financing would usually be based
on invoices you have today
often the financing that greenstone did
was based on
invoices that didn't exist invoices
which were going to exist in the future
it started to emerge that there were
problems at some of these businesses
then he promised that he would
consolidate all the steel businesses
into a single group
and publish a set of consolidated
accounts that was in 2019
we still have seen no accounts the gfg
alliance
it's not even a company it's sort of
this umbrella term
for a web of all these different
companies and some of them are owned by
gupta
and some of them are owned by his father
it really is a dizzying array
of interlinks both from a shareholder
perspective we've got
companies that move from one shareholder
to the next to the next to the next
we have shared directorships with people
who are
still employees of liberty who are
directors of companies
that gupta gfg says they are independent
so it's a huge web are these independent
companies as gfg and gupta keep saying
or are they companies where he has
stronger say than we might think
in terms of what was greensville
financing it's kind of a whole
mess we're talking about hundreds of
different entities here
[Music]
sanjeev gupta loved hobnobbing with
politicians and this proved quite
fruitful in lots of countries he got
support from the states
things really started to get tricky last
year when there was a downturn in the
steel industry
liberty steel his main steel business
had to lay off hundreds of workers in
the uk
sanjeev gupta starts getting uk
government-backed
covid loans so these are loans of
government guarantee and it's supposed
to help businesses
and he's doing this through green sale
there's a 50 million pound cap
on the money one company is supposed to
be able to draw by carving his business
up into lots of different little
companies grinsel was able to draw
hundreds of millions of dollars through
this scheme and now what the financial
times revealed is that in august last
year
he bought a 42 million pound house
in belgravia in his wife's name this is
a huge house it's a six-story
townhouse it's one of the most expensive
property sales
that year this is not some kind of
ordinary family home
this is a very very extravagant purchase
in one of london's most expensive areas
the idea that he was buying that at a
time when he was also
receiving government bailout money has
really struck a chord with a lot of
people so this is a man with a real
taste for luxury
he's got a number of mansions that he
owns these trophy homes
he really loves flying in private jets
the relationship between him and lex
greensell
and their companies was symbiotic really
they end up having
matching lifestyles so lex greenstall
owned a lot of planes
sanjiv gupta ends up owning planes lex
greenstall had a plane that matched
sanjeev gupta's plane they had the same
paint jobs for a company like green
sills that have four private jets
is deeply unusual supply chain finance
it's
not a high margin business i know
another guy in the industry
and he once said to me like rob this is
a great industry
but i fly ryanair kind of reminds me a
bit of philip green
the retail tycoon where people were
quite happy to go along with his
excessive yacht glamorous lifestyle
when jobs were safe and pensions were
safe when that was no longer the case
the reputation of philip green took a
massive nose dive and gupta is not the
household name that philip greene is
but i think his reputation is going to
be heading in a very similar direction
there's a lot of unanswered questions
around trading relationship
between gupta and very closely connected
individuals but also what we've
discovered recently
green sales administrator was having
trouble verifying some of the invoices
there's invoices that green salt
financed for gupta
and the companies say that they never
did any business they have never done
any business with them
he said he couldn't have done what he's
done without the support of green cell
because of the nature of the businesses
that he was buying
he also a traditional bank wasn't going
to be that keen to finance these
acquisitions
so here's where greensell came in it's
not just finance it's not just business
politics is a huge part of the story
jeremy haywood was one of the most
powerful civil servants
in the country for years he worked for
morgan stanley where he met
lex greensell and really took him under
his wing
the most senior civil servant in britain
he was the head of the entire civil
service
he's a character of great probity
intelligence and
integrity and yet somehow jeremy
hayward's head seems to have been turned
by this guy lex greenstill he convinced
david cameron
that he was very smart and he had
brilliant ideas lex became an advisor
to david cameron he had an official
business card
um which linked him to to the prime
minister
lex greenster was given a desk inside
number 10. no one quite knew
why this guy had free reign throughout
whitehall he was trying to sell supply
and chain finance
his ideas only ended up translating into
one project which was a pharmacy
scheme it seems deeply unusual for
clever banker to be sat
in the room with these politicians
big question that no one's been able to
answer and jeremy haywood sadly died two
years ago so he can't answer it either
it's why anyone thought this was a
better idea than the government
simply paying suppliers quicker which
they had the power to do
to be sort of enmeshed in the corridors
of power
in the uk it's it's totally unheard of
you have this incredible access
you know the kind of access that most
entrepreneurs starting businesses could
never dream of and it perhaps speaks to
the salesmanship of lex greenstall
that he was able to get himself in the
room
fast forward a few years and david
cameron had been prime minister for six
years
he leads the remain side of the eu
referendum he loses by 52-48
and he quits straight away and then in
2018 he's offered this job by lex
greensell
who of course he already knows because
greensell was advising him
there's also another civil servant who
was in charge of 40 billion of
government procurement called bill
crothers he also
started working for greenfield these
civil servants are almost
as important as david cameron in this
whole story there was talk about the
business being worth eventually
something like
seven billion dollars david cameron
ended up with share options equivalent
to something like one percent
of the company david cameron's
investment
would have been worth something up to 70
million dollars i'm sure david cameron's
already quite a wealthy man but
you know this would have been very
lucrative obviously those options that
david cameron had that we assume
worth nothing now you then have several
years where he is going around the world
alongside lex greensteal
david cameron lex greenstall they went
on a camping trip with the crown prince
of saudi arabia
you know this wasn't a passive role that
david cameron played in the business
he was opening doors and he was helping
lex greenstall wow
people around the world he's less an
advisor more emissary of influence until
it all comes crashing down
coronavirus strikes renzo wanted access
to coveted loan schemes
and it was having some difficulty
getting approval david cameron
rang rishi sanak he texted rishi sanek
our chancellor
the government was setting up four or
five different
debt schemes in order to help companies
that were struggling because of the
pandemic
greensville got no fewer than 10
meetings with the two most senior
simple servants in the treasury you
think about how desperate companies were
you know not many companies had a former
prime minister in their midst
who was ringing the chancellor in charge
of the nation's finances
there are all sorts of lobbying scandals
here and there but
it's incredibly rare for them to involve
a former cabinet minister
directly asking his mates his former
colleagues for a favor
this whole episode really threatened to
tarnish
the legacy and reputation of david
cameron a former prime minister
who himself introduced rules around
corporate lobbying i think he thought
this was an opportunity to make a big
success in business
we've been trying to reach david cameron
the one time i managed to get hold of
him on his mobile phone
he said can you talk to my office i said
your office has been stonewalling me for
two weeks
and he hung up for someone who said in
2010 the next big political scandal is
going to be about lobbying there's a
certain irony there
greensol bank is a core part of this
story this bank is
nearly 100 years old he bought it and
renamed it it's in bremen
german regulators had started looking
into how
closely linked greensville bank was with
sanjeev gupta it's providing large
amounts of opaque financing to one
person
the managers of the bank are under
criminal investigation for alleged
balance sheet manipulation
you can get three years in prison for
this in germany it's no joke
greensell's trick was to take this area
of
unsexy finance and turn it into
investment securities
they would basically package unpaid
bills
into securities called notes they took
these notes and then sold them to
investment funds
and one of the biggest investors was the
swiss asset manager gam
we had jeremy hayward earlier we have
tim haywood now he was a british fund
manager but he worked for a swiss farm
but he was providing large amounts of
financing
to green sill and greensell was using it
to fund gupta hayward got suspended by
gam
he put some of these green sill
investment products into
funds that let investors withdraw their
money daily
but they're actually really hard to sell
a lot of gupps's debt
ended up stuck in the funds credit
spreads are really important in all of
this
it's set up these supply chain finance
funds credit suisse's
really rich clients would invest in
greenfield stuff
greenstone was saying it's fine that
we're packaging up all of this
debt and selling it on because it's all
insured
and so it's safe this is a safe
investment as a safe asset class in the
summer of 2020
the company that was providing the
insurance said
hang on a minute we're not so sure about
this anymore credit swiss pulled the
plug on the funds
and now its clients could be losing
billions a couple of years back we came
across credit suisse and the supply
chain finance fund
in a huge fraud called nmc health
which even then in 2019 started raising
questions as to the
validity of a lot of this debt that was
in there when david cameron was lobbying
the treasury
the credit swiss funds had financed a
lot of green source clients
that were going bust the thing that
really tipped greensville capital
over the edge was the insurance we find
out that there's a hearing going on in
court
to put this company into administration
that was when it became clear quite how
much exposure the company had to sanjeev
gupta
five billion dollars of exposure to
gupta's companies
no bank in the world would extend that
much credit to sanjiv gupta's steel
works
gupta's gfg alliance group also went to
the uk government recently and they did
ask for a 170 million pound bailout
which the uk government has actually
refused
we're talking about the corridors of
power people who are driving
expensive cars or flying expensive
planes
behind gfg alliance you've got real
people who work in real steel companies
who
might be losing their jobs britain's
business secretary quasi quartering said
that the reason
the government refused the plea for
money were two things one is the opaque
structure of gupta's gfg alliance group
and also because there were concerns
that the money might go
ashore and not actually stay within the
uk
gupta's modus operandi has involved
making bold promises of renewal and
investments
but it's never been matched by the kind
of financial transparency that you would
expect
if you ask the workers at his plans
they're still taking him out his word
he's come out and he said i'm looking
for long-term financing
i'm going to do the best i can and and
the workers at the moment
are backing that they're saying you know
sandeep is saying this is what's
happening we believe him
someone like sanjiv gupta is very
appealing someone who comes in and says
i have a magic formula
i'm not going to fire anyone you can see
why that was quite alluring to
politicians
but they're perhaps now learning that if
something sounds too good to be true it
probably is
what's astonishing i think is that a lot
of the issues scam
credit suisse problems questions raised
about gfg aligned
questions about green sales business
model questions about green cell bank
had all been out in the open before
david cameron made those approaches to
the treasury
this is an incredible fall from grace
for lex greensell a man who was
celebrated as a financial visionary what
this story will
ultimately be remembered for it's the
way that lex greenster was able to
persuade people that
some pretty mundane factoring business
was
some incredible high-tech solution high
finance still has the power to
confuse or to bedazzle most of us i mean
there is a big question here for the
regulators where were the regulators
why was the government why did so many
people jump on the bandwagon of
greedsell
there are echoes of 2008 in this scheme
the subprime mortgage disaster was all
about people thinking
the complicated financial products that
financial engineering
could make bad loans magically safe
it's the same thing here when people
come along with
promises of great investments or when
they say that they've reinvented
an age-old form of finance or that they
can rejuvenate industries
a real dose of skepticism needs to be
applied
this story has such far-reaching
consequences
there's a lot of jobs at stake you know
a lot of people work in the steel making
industry
and their lives are in his hands to some
extent now and that's the really
important issue
it's a good lesson about the hype around
technology
the stuff that greenstone was doing it
was it's centuries old really
financing invoices goes back to the
middle ages the idea that
ai and machine learning could magic away
all the risk in it
it's just a fantasy
[Music]